[Music]
the nation that approaches its god in
the cult of the religion of art is the
ethical nation that knows its state and
the actions of the state to be the will
and the achievement of its own self
this spirit confronting the
self-conscious nation
is therefore not the divine light which
being devoid of a self does not contain
within it
the self-certainty of the individuals
but is only their universal essence and
the lordly power in which they disappear
the cult of the religion of this simple
amorphous essence gives back to its
voters therefore
in general merely this that they are the
people of their god who secures for them
not only their enduring existence and
their substance as
such not however their actual
self which on the contrary is rejected
for they reverence their god as the
empty
depth not as spirit
but the cult of the religion of art on
the other hand
is without that abstract simplicity of
the essence
and therefore of its depth that essence
however which is immediately united with
the self
is in itself spirit and the truth that
is
a knowing though still not the truth
that is known or the truth that knows
itself in the depths of its nature
because then the essence here contains a
self its manifestation is well disposed
towards
consciousness and in the cult
consciousness receives not only the
general sanction
of its enduring existence but also its
conscious
existence in the cult itself just as
conversely the essence does not have an
actuality devoid
of self in a rejected people whose
substance merely is acknowledged
but in the people whose self is
acknowledged
in its substance
paragraph 720 is
leading us into a new subsection of the
religion portion of the work
this is the living work of art by
contrast to the previous sub-section
which
is the abstract work of art so we're
going to want to see some
differentiation between them what we're
going to see in this paragraph however
is
actually a contrast between what's going
on
in this section of religion
religion in the form of art and the
previous section which had to do with
natural religion right and a particular
form that hegel seems to view as maybe
most advanced before we get to the
uh the the person who's fabricating
images we're looking at a stance of
you know religion as a religion of light
the divine light the lord
which we could identify to some degree
with hegel's
picture not the reality of course but
his picture of zoroastrianism
and what we're seeing here in this
section
is a development towards something that
should be more
le bendiga lively living
in terms of what the object
of religion actually is and we've
already seen in the previous
paragraphs this cult the
the locus of worship the sets of
rituals beliefs of the
what he's calling the ethical nation as
a place in which mediation is taking
place in a place in which the god can be
encountered being developed we're going
to see that much more
in this section and then we're going to
be leading into the
third and final subsection of this
religion
in the form of art looking at
language once again so in this paragraph
what we really have is a big contrast
being developed and it's important in
part not just because there's a
dialectical development
but because we're getting to see what
kind of
progress is taking place at least
within the communities that hegel is
willing to
identify as you know the ethical
nation now a bit of a side note
this is the uh greek city-state
right so if you think about hegel's own
particular
vision of history this would no longer
be
the city state by the time that we have
you know the earlier sections stoicism
skepticism unhappy
consciousness arising on the scene if
you look at hegel's
philosophy of history you know once the
greek city-state has been subsumed into
the macedonian empire
it's kind of over as far as like the
development of spirit within
greece other than you know athens being
a place for philosophy and then you know
things are going to shift to the to the
roman side
but i don't think that we need to be
necessarily chained or beholden to
hegel's own views upon this and we could
perhaps you know read in his
religion of the ethical nation into many
other of the
world religions and you know
particularized religions that we could
encounter if we're you know doing good
comparative work
all right so all that said let's look at
the actual contrast
he begins by saying the nation
the folk that approaches its god in the
cult
of the religion of art is the
ethical sitelist nation that
knows its state and the actions of the
state to be the will
and the achievement of its own
self so we we have two things being
connected here we have the
shot the state right the governing body
and then we have the people the nation
the folk
and through religion now this is where
it gets a little bit interesting you
might say
well wait a second you know the
the greek city-states were not
theocracies
so how does this fit in well you know
they weren't theocracies
as such where the religious rulers are
dominating everything but the religion
was an integral part of the state and
there's a back and forth
thing and the people are also involved
there
and what does he mean by an ethical
nation we should remind ourselves of
this it doesn't mean that everybody's
ethically pure and
wonderful or anything like that
zintliches
is uh being contrasted to
say more alicia's you know the moral
nation that has a bunch of rules and
and you know work things out or actually
because it goes back to the zida
you can say more ace right in latin or
the
uh ethe the customs the
habits the traditions and the
differentiation that takes place within
the community by by which people are
assigned their roles and
either fulfill them or don't fulfill
them and there's a lot of back and forth
within any real
ethical nation where there's some
criticism going on and some innovation
and a lot of discussion and there can be
controversies right
so this is a lively state
you could say and we're going to be
contrasting
this so this nation knows its state and
the actions of the state to be the will
and achievement of its own self that's
really central
for hegel in this this knowing
uh on the one hand and this
appropriation the fact that
what is happening in this is no longer
just
pushed off to the gods we're not just
the playthings of the gods
we are agents we are engaging
you might say even cooperating with or
implementing
the will of the gods we are communing
with them as we saw
in the previous section so he goes on
and he says this spirit
confronting now notice what else he says
the self-conscious
nation now it's no longer
self-consciousness is the
self-consciousness
of the individual the nation itself
is conscious of itself and we could say
that
this is happening in part through its
religious commitments and rituals
it's also happening through language the
language is the medium of
self-consciousness
not only for individuals but even more
so
for communities so even though language
isn't being talked about here
it's playing in a really important role
so he says the spirit confronting the
self-conscious nation
is not therefore the divine light
which being devoid of itself does not
contain within it the self-certainty of
the individuals
so there's something that was missing in
this previous
shape of religion remember too that
going back to the very beginning of the
religion section
hegel has set one of the tasks for
religion that
of reconciling or uniting or bringing
together
consciousness and self-consciousness and
that is part of how religion
is spirit so we had a
less developed a not completely adequate
actually in many respects inadequate
shape
of religion earlier on with this
religion of the divine light and one
aspect
is that it is devoid of a self
what's devoid of a self are the
individuals devoid of a self
no they have a self but it's not a self
that is united with the divine
self right instead of being a self it's
something like a force
it's something like a thought or
something like the physical
manifestation in terms of
light say the light of the sun or the
light of the fire
so he says a little bit more it's only
their universal essence
the um olga minus vase
right and here
you know would it be appropriate to
translate vase in as being
essence actually works better
it's their essence but it's an essence
that's lacking
vehicle kite or dozen
actuality or existence
it is universal it's not universal in
the sense of the concrete universal that
unites these individuals together it's
something they can look to and it might
it might actually provide them with a
lot of
you know robust uh interesting stories
and images and narratives and things
like that but it's not something
where they can find themselves
they're being invited in some respect to
lose themselves
in this right so it doesn't contain the
self
certainty of the individuals
only their universal essence and then he
says the lordly power the
herisha macht right so there's something
of worshipping that which shows itself
to be
powerful it makes sense with light right
and the sun
helps makes things grow i mean even
think about plato in
the republic book seven actually book
six as well
what's the one thing that he centers on
to be the analog
in the physical visible world to the
form of the good the sun
right so there's there's something to
this but there's something
missing as well now it's interesting
the translation here voteries right
it's a rather rich term those who make
commitments those who make vows um
uh the anger hurricane right
those who are hearing and obeying those
who are committed to this
this divine light this god that they're
worshiping
what are they they're they're the people
of the god they assume
a type of identity and identification
by virtue of being involved in something
that is a cult
something that there is a a worship
going on there is something
intergenerational there is something
meaningful
right he says the cult of the religion
of this simple amorphous
essence gives back to its voters it
gives them something
in general merely this they are the
people of their god who secures for them
what
who gives them what in return they're
enduring existence they're
bishdein now this is a
a term that hegel is going to use on
both sides
he's used previously bishdein is not the
same thing as
sein vasen dazein it's it's yet another
sort of modality right and he says their
substance as
such uh zubstan super helped right
uh aldzok and so they're getting
something but it's not
something that is really what they
could have and they may not even suspect
that this is missing until they see a
further development further stage
he says as well this is not their actual
self which on the contrary is rejected
so the the voters the worshipers the
cult
members they do have an actual self as
individual human beings but that
is orphan thrown aside
cast away it's not being
part of the relation with the god
by contrast what do we have on the other
side the cult of the religion of art of
the
ethical nation he says that
it is without that abstract simplicity
of the essence and therefore
of that depth right why is he talking
about depth here well because
those who are involved in the cult of
the religion
of the divine light are worshiping
something they are relating to something
something that is you know essential
something that matters something that is
we don't want to say real but has real
effects
but it's empty depth
something that you can recede into
proceed into
follow out but you're not going to find
anything
there it's not spirit there
what's lacking is this interconnection
of things this interaction
that would be there in the cult of the
religion of art so he goes on and he
says
what we're losing here is the abstract
simplicity of the essence and its depth
but that essence which is immediately
united with the self
that essence is is the god right the
essence
is immediately mid middle above right
united with the self is in itself
spirit so spirit is on this side
and he says a truth that is knowing
a truth that is not just known
but which itself is knowing that has
agency that has
mind to it that can enter into relation
with the
worshipers it says though still not the
truth that is known or the truth that
knows itself and then the depth of its
nature there's still something to be
developed
here so then he says because the essence
here contains a self
its manifestation is well disposed
towards consciousness
consciousness is the worshiper what
would be the voters on this side
has now become the conscious worshiper
uh the member of the cult the
participant in the cult
and he says
in the cult consciousness receives not
only as he calls it the general sanction
of its enduring
existence so again we have this bishdein
here right
the general sanction all gemainiga
consciousness is getting that through
the cult in its relation to the
the god in its engagement with it um
but there's more here right he says that
it not only receives that but its
conscious existence
in the cult itself so that's very
interesting
conscious existence and now actually the
way that the german is phrases
in in the cult it receives not only this
but also this so conscious existence
thaz existence that has become
conscious of itself in relation to
things as
as dazzling and he goes on and he says
just as conversely the essence does not
have an actuality
devoid of self a vericly kite that is
lacking self
in a rejected people whose substance is
merely acknowledged
but in the people whose self
is acknowledged honor [ __ ]
right honor kennen is what's at at play
here
in the substance so the people has a
substance
in either side but it's a question of
whether it also has a
self with all that goes along with self
agency contingency communication back
and forth
taking positions on oneself the richness
that is ethical
life within the nation
recognition is is possible here
not over here you're not going to get
recognition
as who you are from the god who
is merely empty depth whereas you will
get it
within the religion of art of the
ethical nation
self-consciousness then comes forth from
the cult
satisfied in its essence and the god
enters
into it as into its habitation
this habitation is by itself the knight
of substance
or its pure individuality but no longer
the tense individuality of the artist an
individuality which has not yet
reconciled itself with its essence
that is in process of becoming objective
it is the satisfied night
of substance which has its pathos within
itself
and it is not in need of anything
because it returns from
intuition from the objectivity that has
been superseded
this pathos is by itself the being of
the risen sun
but a being which has now set within
itself and has its setting or going down
that is self-consciousness and hence
existence and actuality
within itself it has here traversed the
movement
of its actualization coming down
from its pure essential nature and
becoming an objective force of nature
and the expressions of that force
it is an outer existence for the other
for the self by which it is
consumed the silent essence of selfless
nature
in its fruits attains to that stage
where self-prepared and digested it
offers itself to life that has a
self-like nature
in its usefulness as food and drink it
reaches its highest perfection for
in this it is the possibility of a
higher existence and
comes into contact with spiritual
reality
in its metamorphosis the earth spirit
has developed partly into a silently
energizing substance
partly into a spiritual fermentation in
the first case it is the feminine
principle of nourishment in the other
the masculine principle
the self-impelling force of
self-conscious
existence
paragraph 721 is a rather
rich one in its suggestiveness in in
what hegel
is describing here but i think it can be
very confusing
as well to figure out exactly what's
happening
on what side and in relation to
whom and it concludes with something a
little bit weird this
you know masculine and feminine
principles
of things we'll get to that in just a
moment but
we do want to keep in mind where
it is heading
by the end of this paragraph he's going
to talk about
how the god or the essence
is becoming an objective force of nature
a not to a craft which is
offering itself to not just the
individual but
individuals within the cultists the
the religious community that of the
ethical nation and
this is something that you'd think well
this could apply to
not just you know the ethical nation or
the greek city state but to
all sorts of other um religions as well
because we see that
grain and wine or pick whatever else you
want
whatever you know fermented thing there
is
deities abound throughout pretty much
most mythologies most religious systems
if they have something that they do
ferment if they have something
that they do harvest there's usually
going to be
at least some space for that within the
religious system so
what we'll need to think about that a
little bit more but let's see where he
starts he says self-consciousness comes
forth from the cult satisfied
in its essence this satisfaction is
going to be an important factor
it already was in the past but it's
going to be
more and more important as this section
goes on and he says and the god enters
into
it into what into the cult into
self-consciousness
um into something like now here miller
translates it as
habitation could also be
sight so the worshiper or
the worshipers together
the god enters into not just
communication
with them but genuine communion with
them and we've seen
some discussion of habitation of the god
earlier but that was vuonung that was
you know
within the temple now this is within the
framework of the interaction of the cult
and so he says this habitation now this
is
what we're going to be unpacking through
the rest of the
paragraph the habitation is by itself
the night
of substance or it's pure
individuality now here's an interesting
contrast but no longer the
tense individuality of the artist
an individuality in which there is
tension the tension between the artists
the
the you know whether understood as the
quinsler or
the uh the meister the one who
manipulates the materials to try to
create something
that is adequate to the divine that's
being depicted
for the divine as a medium
for the divine right this individuality
is now
the artist was no long was not
reconciled itself with the essence that
is in process of becoming objective
and the artist is indeed part of the
process
of making the divine objective gig and
stendling something that we can actually
look at something that we can
relate to isn't it and you know the
artist
is often well the artist is taking
materials that
the artist didn't generate him or
herself
right wood fabrics metals
and those are coming from nature
transformed by by human activity and
they're also
using images shapes motifs coming
to some degree from nature whether they
be crystalline whether they be
plant-like whether they be animal
whether they be human
but the artist goes beyond that as we
we've seen right making
this this objective he says it's no
longer that now it's the satisfied night
of substance which has its pathos within
it
and is not in need of anything because
it returns from
intuition on xiang right um
from the objectivity that has been
superseded
objectivity is gigan stanley kite
superseded as alph
holben so there has been a
transformation
taking place here a dialectical
transformation that that we
have you know charted out and the
individual
worshiper who is
this site this habitation where the god
is
engaging with them has returned
their you know the
the individuality that they have is not
that of the artist they are able to
enjoy they are able to go beyond
the mere objectivity the gig and stem
they kite of say the idol or
the rituals or whatever else that they
are involved with
um now hegel uses this term pathos
and doesn't really explain what he means
by it or
why he's using that and we should
probably pause on that a bit
after we look at the next thing where he
brings up potholes right he says this
pathos is by itself the being of the
risen sun
but a being which is now set within
itself and has its setting or going down
that is self-consciousness hence
existence and actuality within itself
and so we might
be tempted to read pathos in a couple
different ways
which i don't want to suggest are
completely wrong but
we might say oh okay so pathos here
means something
like deep and paradoxical right
it's both the rising sun and the setting
sun
and both at the same time and oh that
sounds
cool what a cool image right
in a way you could say with any given
sun rise or sunset
if all you if you if you have no context
you actually don't know whether it is a
rising sun or setting sun like if you
don't know
whether it's the east or the west and
you just see a glowing ball of fire and
some clouds
is it the rising or setting sun you
don't know right and and so maybe
there's
something that could be developed there
out of that so
is is that a wrong way of looking at
pothos
i don't know maybe we should also look
at pathos
as sort of a code word for
containing something clearly dialectical
something that
is dialectical in the sense of the
concept in the developed sense
meaning where we ourselves the thinker
not we're not just using representation
but we're actually
grasping the object in its totality
uh going beyond objectivity right
so you know we've got a lot of stuff
here right self-consciousness hence
existence
and actuality within itself
but i think we should actually think
about a different sense of
pothos that might be a little bit more
applicable here going back to an earlier
meaning of it so apotheos in greek
traditional philosophical greek going
back to antiquity
means something that we suffer
something that is done or happens to us
rather than something that we ourselves
are the self-conscious agent of even
within ourselves so
you know the pathe are the emotions as
we call them they're also
other affects and things that you know
we undergo
it becomes one of the categories of
aristotle you know
um there's you know uh
acting and being acted upon or suffering
right
so i think that's part of what's
happening here because if we look
later on in the paragraph what we have
is the god identified as the essence the
vason
making of itself something objective
something that is then available
to the individual to consume
it makes itself passive you could say so
let's let's continue on so
the pathos is by itself the being of the
risen sun
but a being which is now set within
itself
and has its setting or going down that
is
self-consciousness that is it's going
down right and hence existence in
actuality within itself
it is here traverse the movement of its
actualization this is becoming actual
becoming
real becoming ver clique now
he's he goes on and he says coming down
from its pure essential nature
and becoming an objective force of
nature
and the expressions of that force this
is a very interesting way to talk so
we're talking about the god doing this
within the scope of the cult but also
within the scope
of what the cult focuses our attention
on but but is not the cult itself
namely the the reality of the natural
world
and the world that can be harvested
right as the
the natural world um
hegel doesn't actually use nature twice
here in the german so
coming down from its pure essentiality
right
is a better way to frame it and then
becoming
an objective gegenstendrika force of
nature
nature craft and what are what are
forces of nature when we hear that
phrase
we typically think of like oh thunder
lightning wind you know
volcanoes okay sure yeah he doesn't
mention any of that here though
what is he actually going to mention the
fruits of harvesting
gathering agriculture all these things
that
we're going to talk about a little bit
more and he says
it's not just an objective force of
nature it's also the expressions of that
force
and it becomes an outer existence a
dozen for the other the self by which it
is consumed
that's the individual worshiper who is
consuming within the cult but is also
consuming outside of the cult
is consuming pretty much just to stay
afloat stay alive right
and he goes and he says the silent
essence of selfless nature
in its fruits attains to that stage
where self-prepared and digested
it offers itself to life that has a
self-like nature okay so what are we
talking about here
i thought we had this achievement you
know just look at the last paragraph
the god has to have a self right if it's
the god of the ethical nation the god of
the
uh work of art yes yes so that that's
correct
hegel is talking about here
what it is that nature itself does which
then can become a kind of site
a vehicle for the god so think of
for example
berries whatever berries you happen to
eat
and wherever you happen to live there
are many different kinds of wonderful
fruits you know that we call berries
across the world some of them are not
actually
berries apparently like strawberries are
a conglomerate of things so
you know think about like raspberries or
blueberries or
huckleberries or you know gooseberries
or whatever it is that you
happen to have so
hegel says the silent essence of
selfless
nature right nature does what it does
without having a
conscious let alone self-conscious self
it follows certain
pro you know uh procedures certain
processes
certain things that are just built in in
its fruits
attains to its to that stage where
self-prepared
right it does prepare itself um
you know you look at the pollination and
then the germination
you know and and the turning into this
fruity thing that is going to have seeds
within it
that will get you know uh that's the
process of reproduction they're gonna
get eaten and then
they're gonna get you know left
somewhere and then you're gonna get new
plants
this whole process of self-preparing and
we could say digestion
is happening we think of that as what's
happening in our bellies
but it's actually happening you know in
in the ripening so you say we say it
it offers itself to life
that has a self-like nature now that's
an interesting turn of phrase too that
has a self-like nature
so that's definitely us does that
include the other animals
i'll just leave that thought out there
right
now he says in its usefulness as food
and drink it reaches
its highest perfection so
cereals pulses you know
whatever else we're gonna we're gonna
eat whatever we can turn into food
and drink that is the highest perfection
the highest fulfillment of nature not to
say that everything else isn't
important but that's where it really
becomes
what it ought to be and he says in this
is the possibility of a higher existence
and comes into contact with spiritual
reality
so you know like the berries that i'm
shoving into my face
and chewing on because i'm a human being
and enjoying them those berries are in a
certain way
brought to a higher state of existence
by being incorporated
into me somebody who can read hegel and
talk about it or think about the history
or dialectic or
any of these cool sorts of things and
now he's got this weird you know
bring bringing it to an end in its
metamorphosis the earth spirit
has developed partly into a silently
energizing
substance partly into a spiritual
fermentation so
uh silently energizing substance is the
female principle of nourishment
why should nourishment be female i you
know i
i don't really know um you know these
these sorts of things remind me of the
section
much earlier on in the reason uh portion
of the work where he's like looking at
you know acid and base and positive and
negative and a lot of these things are
kind of arbitrary we could
shift them back and forth but in any
case he says
uh the the masculine principle is the
self
impelling force of self-conscious
existence
which is the spiritual fermentation and
now we need to see
where this is actually going he's going
to bring up
um you know male and female again
in just a few paragraphs but i don't i
don't know that that really adds that
much but what we do have is the god
relating itself to us
the worshipers as something to be
consumed and thereby by us
to be transformed into something higher
you